les travaux sur la route départementale
3 appliquons goya bhl dans les eaux de
petites îles sont officiellement lancés
avec un développement croissant de cette
agglomération et une forte augmentation
de l'urbanisation
un réaménagement de la route
départementale est donc primordial on en
profite également pour traiter les
écoulements plus haut sur la chaussée
sur toute la traversée d'agglomération
donc les travaux consistent à faire de
la sécurisation de piétonnes par les
trottoirs par des carrefours surélevée
et de la sécurité on va dire aussi drôle
qu actuellement il existe peu
d'aménagements permettant un cheminement
piéton sécurisé le département investit
donc neuf cent cinquante mille euros sur
ce projet soit deux tiers de son coût
global afin de réaliser un kilomètre 4
de trottoirs sur le tronçon de la route
départementale 3 entre l'allée des
fougères et la rue francis r 3000
véhicules jour ça n'est pas rien
c'est le troisième quartier le plus
urbanisée de la ville de la petite île
c'est un quartier qui bouge
régulièrement il y à une école lit un
passage piéton important on se devait de
répondre à cette à ce besoin de sécurité
de sécurité piétonne un chantier très
attendu par la population de python
goyave
car il permettra de sécuriser le
déplacement de lampions de des piétons
nécessaire parce que bon bah il ya des
gens qui font la moche et que ben
les trottoirs c'est utile pour les
marchés il ya de plus en plus de
marcheurs je vois moi aussi je marche
tous les soirs même pense que les biens
pour les enfants quand les autres mais
ça trahit saveurs à l'école elle est
plus en sécurité tout ça parce que c'est
bien pour la population
sa présence en il y aura moins de
l'histoire les travaux devraient durer
jusqu'à la fin du premier trimestre 2010
est le département bénéficie d'un budget
d'investissement de 25 millions d'euros
par an pour aménager et sécuriser les
routes départementales de la réunion
rappelons que le réseau routier du sud
représente à lui seul 50% des routes
départementales de lille petit il
effectivement à cette chance d'être
l'une des premières communes premier
canton canton 22 à bénéficier de ces
investissements importants 1 million 400
mille euros dont neuf cent mille euros
porté par le département
ce n'est pas rien ce n'est que le début
puisque nous avons mis en place un
programme pluriannuel d'investissement
après piton des goyaves ce seront les
travaux sur ravine du programme in du
conte ce sont 5 millions de travaux qui
vont être engagées dès 2017 avec une
participation du département à hauteur
de 2 millions 5 principalement traversé
par des routes départementales le
secteur de petit il bénéficiera sur le
projet de mandature 2017 et 2021 d'un
financement de 6 millions 200 mille
euros de la part du département afin
d'aménager ses roues